when people go out there they brag about
their numbers and they say we're doing
so great because we're supporting Donald
Trump what you want to know who has more
numbers more reach more traffic than all
political sites all new sites combined
porn let me get into media here and this
is a problem that I have right now I
think this is important everything
that's wrong with media in 2016 and I
think everyone will understand there's a
kernel of truth here at least in your
own life this is the first election here
are some polls rigged yeah the RCP
average has been remarkably accurate as
a matter of fact overly generous to
Romney and McCain particularly Rasmussen
LA Times era polls that are skewed right
they're posted are skewed left how are
the the cumulative of all the polls has
always been over all right the last few
years could be wrong but I'm not going
to lie you say and say that's likely
there's no proof that it's likely yet
there is no proof that all the polls are
over sampling at a plus 15 Democrats
that's that's nice not true the polls
right now show that Donald Trump is very
behind Hillary Clinton is starting with
about 260 electoral votes and she needs
one or two major states Trump needs a
clean sweep it could happen it's
probably not likely this is the first
election where when you said oh man
Romney is is it's not looking great in
the polls no one said screw you you work
for Obama or McCain or with Bush
if you said man it doesn't look good
right now let's go out let's canvass
let's help let's campaign more people
didn't get mad at you for siding effect
let me explain to you why that is it's a
phenomenon here with social media we
thought when we got rid of the
mainstream media sort of gatekeepers
that all of a sudden truth would be
available and we'd be able to get our
information unfiltered instead we've
replaced it with social media corporate
overlords who are actually your portal
to the Internet and even though they
lean left they have an incentive to only
tell you what you want to hear so two
websites let me give you an example you
go on you like content that's Pro Donald
Trump or Pro Hillary Clinton depending
where you line up it says you may also
like right the algorithm is not based on
on any of these sites YouTube Facebook
Twitter Instagram it's not you may also
need to hear you may also need to brush
up on its you may also like and so when
people go out there and they brag about
their numbers and they say we're doing
so great because we're supporting Donald
Trump what you want to know
who has more numbers more reach more
traffic than all political sites all new
sites combined porn Kim card at one
Kardashian because people love boobs and
butts they love big asses they love porn
they love naked ladies so guess what you
can make more clicks doesn't mean it's
what they need
doesn't mean it's helpful in the same
bet people who love you can bet on
people who love Donald Trump they're
going on reading Hillary's corrupt the
email scandal
Hillary sucks bills are rapists anything
critical of Trump no no no you're not
gonna like you're not gonna share people
who love Hillary Donald Trump's a sexual
assault or Donald Trump's a pedophile
Donald Trump's corrupt they're gonna let
me give you an example a tale of two
people a mom she logs onto Facebook for
the first time she creates a profile
this election her daughter goes to
college daughters Hillary mom is Trump
mom goes on likes Trump's page make
America great again like we're winning
in the polls like Hillary Clinton's grew
up like WikiLeaks like the girl from
college Pro Hillary she liked Hillary's
page Donald Trump is not releasing his
tax returns like Donald Trump is a
racist like Donald Trump is a rapist
like and guess what this goes on for a
few months eventually you go an entire
six months year two years without ever
having read once a different opinion
even if you know it's true even the
woman who's on a pro Trump page where it
says oh my gosh it looks like he's down
Pennsylvania's no longer a toss-up not
like down vote click not share so you
never see it so you only read the pro
Trump stuff and she's only reading the
pro Hillary stuff to the point where you
couldn't be less informed and the people
who are creating these news stories are
incentivized no longer to tell you the
truth but they're actually beholden 100%
the only way they survive is by creating
content that you want to hear if they
create any content that's important and
truthful that you don't want to hear
they don't show it to you because it
doesn't get a like it doesn't get an
upvote it doesn't get a click and so
they lie to you and that's a real
problem on either side and that's why
there's this divide and that's why
people are really uninformed of other
arguments and that's why when Rush
Limbaugh says don't pay attention to the
polls you will never hear this program
ever how many times have I said set
huffington post set salon.com to some of
your favorites go in you'll never hear
me try and encourage you to limit
information let me give you some
examples with our own page this is a
struggle that we've had if we post
anything critical in our page anything
critical on our website we do many many
millions of
viewers were incredibly grateful and we
have the luxury of being able to be
truthful so let's get this up if we put
up a post right here where Donald Trump
said he was going to sue the press over
negative coverage this only got about
hundred and thirty six thousand reach on
Facebook right because it wasn't super
Pro Trump because we didn't like that he
was going after the First Amendment if
you look at the comments on that too
right away people comment on it and they
say I can't believe that you would say
this contrast that with a Hillary post
take it from about same sitting
working-class people out of work four
hundred and sixty two thousand reach
let's do the other one the second
amendment one here's two Donald Trump
wants to ban Americans from buying guns
we put it up only a four hundred
thousand people reach people got really
mad show the comments knocking Jared
they said how dare you this is
brainwashed why are you reporting this
you need to support Trump same story
Hillary anti gun seven hundred and
eighty-five thousand reach every single
person likes it same audience same issue
show him another meme on a Hillary reach
right here a meme that is truthful
these are posts that are anti Hillary
Clinton over two million reach over 6
million reach on our paltry little
Facebook page what does that tell you
now here's the deal is that great for us
red-meat lines of course those are our
biggest traffic pieces and when Hillary
Clinton lied about pneumonia we covered
it but we didn't lie to you which we
knew would have generated way more
traffic with the Parkinson's which
everyone knows is not true now because
she doesn't have Parkinson's but you've
forgotten about it and moved it on to
the next scandal we didn't lie to you
for more clicks we could lie to you and
tell you a bunch of falsehoods about
Hillary and a bunch of falsehoods about
Donald Trump wherever you line up and
ensure that we get more traffic and
clicks and we're more profitable by
keeping you in the dark not only could
we do it if we wanted to grow if we
wanted to work in the social media
environment right now it's what people
have to do so it is your job to inform
yourself on both side and not get
offended when someone comes up with
facts and what I want you to do is not
only with this election but win lose or
draw understand and look back that the
guys who are comedians who play spot the
[ __ ] and later tonight we'll play
hipster hobo if Nick DiPaolo gosh they
didn't line us they were pretty
consistent we're looking beyond not just
this election and just be aware of how
you're being marketed to
video subscribe or click what's playing
next to me it's taken from the full show
that's right every week the full two
something our podcast that's never going
daily and it's never going daily stop
asking but it's free you can go watch it
play it in your car it's better than
texting and driving